good morning John it's beach service
everybody that you know this and if you
miss the fun we're gonna have a rub your
face in it
vlog brothers videos every day except
for weekends because we need a break a
mistake that I made was doing this at
all because Hank green wrapping is
always always always a bad idea you know
John I'm actually getting a little
worried that we're gonna acquire so many
traditions here on vlogbrothers that
eventually every day will be prescribed
it will have something from the history
of nerdfighteria to do that day this is
the PISA John he's crooked I think all
of our traditions and inside knowledge
are wonderful but I can be intimidating
for people who are new to missus just a
two-week period where John and I make
videos every day like we used to back
when we first started doing this in 2007
motherhood 2.0 that's what that was
called I honestly don't even know where
Pizza this came from I did a video last
year on the history of Pizza John which
is this sure if you confused about that
please watch that video I worked hard on
it and I think it's good also doing
Pizza miss as you may have noticed we do
pizza John's and various styles these
are only available during pizza miss
they're for preorder during this
two-week period and then they'll never
happen again I didn't have any of mine
cuz I tend to give them away during the
project for awesome which is another
thing project for awesome
if you are not aware is the thing that
John and I have been doing since 2007
since the very first year of law brother
basically it's saying hey instead of
uploading whatever video you're gonna
upload on this day instead upload a
video about a charity that you like that
you think does good work a little bit of
promotion for the in addition to that we
also do a 48 hour livestream we have
lots of guests and we do lots of weird
things and we have lots of fun lots of
memes are created new traditions it's
great so the ways you can participate in
the project for awesome are you can make
a video promoting a charity you can
donate money through the IndieGoGo
campaign which is the thing that we will
have for about a week and a bunch of
cool stuff that you can get through that
campaign we're getting stuff from
youtubers and other internet people all
over to donate you can watch the
livestream and tell people to come watch
the live stream watch project for
awesome videos promote the
just general idea of the project for
awesome and you can vote on the project
for awesome videos that you like the
month during the first ever the project
for awesome all of the money raised is
gonna be split between Save the Children
and the UN a High Council on refugees
during the second half of the project
for awesome the money is going to be
distributed to the charities featured
and the videos that get the most votes
from the community so by voting you get
to influence where this pot of money is
going to go and in the last few years
it's been more than a million dollars
those videos if you're gonna make one
are gonna be uploaded at midnight on
December 11th that's right when it
becomes December 11 I just been all
weekend watching the extra life live
streams that the gaming community on
YouTube and twitch doing it's just got
me super dressed for the project for
awesome so if you wanna make a project
for awesome video start thinking about
that now I will also link to a video
where I explain what I think makes a
good project for awesome video if you
want to take some of that advice this
one feels funny it's really soft on the
inside though oh and I should say this
one costs extra and all of the proceeds
from it will go to the point foundation
which is an LGBTQ scholarship fund John
I am excited to see you tomorrow and
also on Thursday and then Monday
Wednesday and Friday of next week it's
Pizza ves I'll see you on Tuesday
these shirts are again available at
dftba.com and will never be available
again they have tear off tags so you
don't have to worry about the tags
getting in your way I love this it's
also just satisfying I think there's one
is the favorite I don't know it's just
exceptionally funny to me I wore it all
all day today also doing pizza in this
we've got a pizza John or Anna meant a
snap back of Window Cling some stickers
on a travel mug which only available now
and then never again never I got